hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm going to share with you how you can
eat bacon and lose your fat and I'm not
kidding I'm actually totally serious so
just hear me out okay
I have this reference book it's called
Guyton's physiology I want to share
something with you but before I do I
want to ask you a quick question do you
know the hormone that acts as a primary
switch but determines whether your body
burns fat or sugar fuel do you know what
hormone that is let me share with you
some page
nine-thirty okay since the role of
insulin in switching between
carbohydrate and lipid metabolism that
means the role of insulin in switching
between sugar and fat all right when the
glucose concentration is low when
there's no sugar in the body insulin
secretion is suppressed and fat is
utilized almost exclusively for energy
okay so basically insulin is the main
hormone that controls whether you are
going to burn fat exclusively or you're
just going to burn sugar okay so let me
show you something okay so you probably
already know that eating sugar triggers
insulin right and that's part of the
glycemic index which basically is an
index of all the foods and how fast they
turn into sugar and raise your blood
sugar right so that's kind of a known
thing and you probably know that sugar
is bad so you avoid it and some of you
are losing weight but some of you aren't
because the glycemic control over
insulin is only 50% of what raises
insulin there are other reasons why
insulin could be high and there's even a
scale called the insulin index that I'm
going to talk about so this is going to
shock you if we take a look at the
insulin index there are foods that do
not trigger the glycemic index but do
increase insulin the ones low on the
list are the fats the butter the coconut
oil the bacon bacon is only 9% that is
why bacon is actually good to lose
weight because it
doesn't affect insulin as we go up the
list the foods that affect it more and
more egg yolks is low because it's
mostly fat but egg whites are 55%
amazing it's a concentrated protein look
at whey protein is 71 percent what does
that mean it means that the more lean
you go with your proteins the more low
fat the more it stimulates insulin this
is exactly what people have been
focusing on the lose weight but it's
having a rebound effect it's much better
if you have whole fat products like
don't buy lean meat buy the fatty meats
okay
the bacon and it's totally okay okay so
that's one thing I want to talk about
now there's other things too alright so
we know certain proteins stimulate
insulin to a certain degree some more
than others
we know fat does not stimulate insulin
especially if it's pure fat and bacon
would be more fat than protein but
there's something else
gut hormones really I mean gut hormones
means every time you eat anything you're
going to get some spike in insulin okay
now what does that have to do with
anything it means this if you're having
breakfast lunch and dinner and you're
eating snacks in between even if they're
healthy you are creating an insulin
response now remember we're trying to
take insulin and bring it way way way
way down right so the best thing to do
and this is why intermittent fasting is
very very very good to lower insulin not
necessarily lower your calories to
create starvation but to lower the
frequency of meals that you consume it's
just as important of what you eat so the
frequency so let's say in the morning
you have breakfast and you're you're
basically you want to go from breakfast
to lunch without any snacks we want to
go from lunch to dinner without any
snacks we don't want to eat anything
after dinner that would be a very
important thing to improve insulin in
general okay now if in the morning
you're not hungry don't eat so you want
to basically go as long as you can
then eat when you're hungry because that
way we keep insulin down again these are
very powerful tips to be able to get
into fat-burning most people graze so
much and they're thinking more meals
it's going to stimulate metabolism it
really doesn't is you're going to keep a
constant stimulation of insulin and
eventually you're going to get a
condition called insulin resistance
where your body now does not do good
with insulin and even when you don't eat
the insulin is higher the way that you
would know you have insulin resistance
is if you can't go between one male and
another without getting seriously hungry
because an insulin resistance if you
take a look at this here's insulin
resistance and this is a normal cell an
insulin resistance you only have a
little bit of fuel that goes into the
cell because it's resisting insulin and
glucose in a normal cell you have
glucose that goes in there pretty nicely
so basically the cells and insulin
resistance are kind of starving of
nutrition that's why when you eat you
might eat your food but you're still not
satisfied you need a little something
sweet or some quick energy because the
cells are starving of nutrition so that
means your insulin has to go higher and
higher to actually work better
so that's the condition where you have
symptoms of hypoglycemia and
hyperglycemia you can have like high
sugar and low sugar symptoms at the same
time so you crave sweets you get tired
after a meal you're not satisfied you
can't go for very long without getting
hungry so that's just all it's a good
indicator to see if you have been some
resistance or not if you have belly fat
you have insulin resistance okay if you
have belly fat you have a fatty liver
most most of the time and a fatty liver
can then create insulin resistance
because a lot of that problem occurs in
the liver so the point is to get out of
the situation we want to avoid what
originally caused the problem which is a
high sustained level of incident over a
long period of time so we want to be
careful not to stimulate this incident
too much so what does fat have to do
with this what is bacon have to do with
this
bacon allows you to number one go longer
without eating to satisfy you it also
does not trigger insulin so it's the
perfect food or any fats for that matter
to get you to go from one meal to the
next comfortably so you're not dropping
your blood Sugar's okay so it's just
more satisfying
now some people get up in the morning
they're not hungry until lunch well then
just eat one meal at lunch and then
they'll have one dinner and that's fine
so two meals are totally fine you can do
that okay this is just one technique
that can help fix this and help you lose
weight but you're going to need to add
adjust your fats because if you can't go
from breakfast to lunch without being
ravenously extremely hungry and that
means you have to add a little bit more
fat to your breakfast
same thing with dinner if you're if
you're extremely hungry at dinner you
have to add a little bit more fat at
that lunch okay if you're extremely
hungry at night add a little more fat
and you can keep adjusting it into your
satisfied that's how you can have more
fat especially bacon now if you're
concerned about having high cholesterol
by eating bacon here's the truth all of
the the parts of the systems in the body
work on a feedback mechanism which means
that if you eat more of one thing your
body will reduce this thing over here
and I'm talking about the liver the
liver makes 2,000 milligrams of
cholesterol every single day okay that's
like a dozen eggs so if you eat more
cholesterol your body will just adjust
from the feedback loops and actually
make less it's real simple
where cholesterol comes into play it's
the carbohydrate that you're eating that
converts insulin converts sugar into bad
cholesterol and triglycerides it's not
the fat that you're eating it does that
that's been thoroughly proven I'll put
some links below okay and you can study
that but I'm not going to get into that
in this this section but here's the
other thing that will trigger insulin
cortisol
what does cortisol cortisol is that
stress hormone now in some of the other
videos I've done I've talked about the
relationship between
to salt in belly fat but the
relationship is this cortisol releases
glucose and sugar it turns your protein
into sugar okay even when you don't eat
sugar so if there's a stress state or
you're going through menopause or even
you're diabetic
your cortisol is going to go up it's
going to release more sugar and then
that sugar is going to stimulate insulin
so really the insulin is doing the
damage but the cortisol is helping it do
the damage okay and so what we want to
do is lower stress one of the biggest
things that I talked about is to improve
and fix your sleep I have separate
videos on that you can watch but sleep
is very very beneficial and you can also
do more exercise exercise will improve
insulin it lowers insulin as well
because it's going to get rid of the
excess sugar that's stuck there
okay so cortisol is something to look at
these other intra minute fasting don't
snack anymore that's going to help add a
little bit of fat between meals
now I'll I pretty much have about five
things that bacon every morning and my
cholesterol is really good and that just
satisfies me if you're a smaller person
have less but I'm just telling you if
you have a high quality bacon there's
nothing wrong with that at all okay and
then be careful of your proteins
especially whey proteins okay I hope you
learned something I will see you in the
next video